I feel like I've lost a friend today
I feel like that's the takeaway from
this whole thing one can dream hey there
I'm Nicholas Garden
and I'm Taylor Chicago Perez you
sabotaged mine you put it way too big a
pause I'm Nicholas Gallatin I'm Nicholas
Galaxy oh God this I want to go home
hey there I'm Nicholas Galaxy and I'm
terrible zakara Perez and today we are
doing the UK versus US GQ friendship
quiz you got it thank you mate Tyler's a
corporation can you do an impression of
me please may
how is it what's up
can I get a latte I agree on my latte
yeah great thanks babes
that is
everyone's my friend I'm just very
excited to see them I'm just I'm very
enthusiastic I will give him the point
for that I think that was very good
acting Taylor well done you're gonna
make something of yourself one day in
this industry thank you so much can you
do an impression of it yes I can here it
goes hey what's up I'm Taylor zakar
Perez you might might have seen my work
in the kissing booth or this uh this
other movie called one up
how dare you freaking love to Surf take
supplements gotta get that collagen in
your skin dude Gotta Get It gotta look
young gotta look hot always yeah that
this is me Taylor Taylor freaking
Taylor I think you nailed it thank you
yeah Taylor can you point to where the
king of England lives on this map now
I'm going to show you a map now we know
Americans are not great at geography
they only really care about States
American states
so this might be difficult for Taylor so
um here we go I'll hold it up there is
this not this area
very good Taylor very good okay Taylor
is the one American person who knows
what London is on a map congratulations
oh yeah where is Indiana Indiana's in
the Midwest
right I can either confirm nor deny
Indiana Indiana
I'm trying to think what the state would
be okay so we've got California here
we've got uh Arizona New Mexico
yeah did you want to touch Nevada like
that again Nevada yeah Indiana
that's right there perfect
it's that it's that it's yes it's it's a
point it's right there and the bonus
question is what is the major sport
event in Indiana known as the big game
the big football game
the bowl the Indiana Bowl
the great state champion lacrosse game
of Indiana think of racing oh it's the
Indy 5 500 yeah 5 000 would be would be
great that was two points right I was
very leading yeah you can have it Taylor
which of these three is not a real place
in the UK is it a
scratchy bottom is it me Sandy bush
is it C bell end you know what that is I
told you yeah yeah I want to say bell
end is not real is that your final
answer Taylor yeah are you sure yeah the
answer is in fact B but there is also a
place uh as GQ is telling me now called
Sandy ball is it just coming in it's
coming in Through the Wire I'm hearing
that we have live news and there is a
place called Sandy balls in the UK you
get 10 points for that congratulations
thank you so much wait wait did I get it
right yeah no no you didn't sorry sorry
you didn't you didn't get it scratch
that scratch that from the point Sally
all right where is the tallest building
in the U.S and what is it we think it
used to be New York I want to say
Seattle it isn't you you shouldn't say
Seattle okay it's in New York is it it's
is it the
them
Empire
if you go south there is a larger
building yeah it's more of like a center
point in what county does the annual
Coopers Hill cheese roll take place I
believe you competed in this event
yourself didn't you I'm lactose
intolerant
would it be Yorkshire it's not Yorkshire
but I'm actually kind of impressed that
you know Yorkshire Devonshire no it's
also a type of cheese manchego
Manchego County
the county of Munster no but I keep this
is really quite funny I could do this
for the next 20 minutes provolone County
it is correct provolone County uh no
it's gloucestershire gloucestershire
cheese
is that a cheese it is a cheese right
can you name the last five presidents
Joe Biden Donald Trump
Obama
George Bush
oh um I did not have yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I had the sexual relations oh my
God why am I getting your name oh my God
okay Bill Clinton yes nice that was good
thanks man cheers Stateside Taylor what
does three million Brits tune into for
16 weeks a year this is a good one it's
it's love Island yes very good Taylor
very good what is the line what does he
say you are a lion you are a liar
cows that's David there from last year's
love Island you do not say that that is
my thing
and then the next episode when she tried
to say what he said oh I don't I don't
remember
somebody watched it what is the most
watched sport in the U.S I want to say
American football you should say it
that's correct okay
for Nick
you're Taylor I'm I'm Nick okay got it
what would I use a rubber for in the UK
in the most common sense what would I
use a rubber for think about like what
you do with a rubber like think about
like if you if it was gonna be a thing
like what would you do with it I would
put it on
thank you it's not that good I know but
I mean then give me a better description
you want that's bad I led you astray
that I think it's fair I'll give you a
clue it is a piece of stationery oh um
is it a eraser yes very good you should
go in the convenience store in the
states and ask for a rubber I don't know
if English people know what that means
over there you said you put it on
you're sick okay if someone says it's
breakouts today what are they referring
to is it like it's like cold yeah really
cold yeah is that something Americans
say yeah if someone is having a chin wag
what are they doing like pulling my
chain like joking with you no but that's
not a bad guess chin wag like right now
you me having a chin wag an interview
a chat how yes you're having a
conversation you're having a
conversation like I mean my mate just
having a chin wag I'll give him a point
all right the points that are Bountiful
and plenty but you don't need to be
stingy with them yeah this is a game of
friendship if anything name three dishes
on the Thanksgiving table you're at your
turkey you got cranberry sauce and
Brussels sprouts bonus point for every
additional dish you can name roasted
carrots maybe you might have roasted
potatoes just roast everything just
roast them all you learned on set
remember the last day of shooting well I
mean you have gravy oh oh
cornbread yeah what is a chip party
Taylor how's it spelled
b-u-t-t-y is that fish and chips no it's
quite a weird thing it's like conflating
two things because you guys called
french fries chips crisps are chips but
what's the butter mayonnaise no butter
don't think condiments sandwich yes what
is it goes in the sandwich it's fish
it's you guys speak a different language
here I'm telling you it may be English I
feel like we did like all the workings
out a sandwich and fries yes
we're trying to work around the fish and
chips of it all no I was never on board
with fish and chips Nicholas yes what is
a corn dog it's like a weird thing that
goes on a stick I mean is it made of
corn I don't know it's it's like it
looks kind of like a big hot dog it goes
on a stick and you kind of yeah it's
like a corn bread battered wiener is it
always in butter yeah
what can I expect in a traditional
English fryer
fish
you really you're really about to upset
me an English fry up chips
I have no idea getting really angry
right now otherwise known as a full
English wait that's just like a
breakfast I've never heard it called a
fire there's always like baked beans in
there okay mushrooms yeah tater tots or
like some kind of that's an American
thing your main thing is your your eggs
your bacon toast sausages but then you
can add mushrooms you can add tomatoes
you know all of this you love tomatoes
can you describe how to make ants on a
log
the log in question is it chocolate no
is it a bread type thing no is it savory
very neutral very neutral thing it's a
neutral food yeah it's like a little bit
bitterness to it maybe it's like a
refreshing but kind of bitter can you
give me an example of a neutral food a
radish is kind of a neutral food oh God
you know just kind of like is it a
radish is a neutral food yeah there's
like a slight kick too okay I want to
say it's raisins okay on a cucumber
close it's it's a celery and then you
put uh peanut butter in it and then you
put oh the ants on top what are the ends
there isn't well they are it is raisins
I think that's worthy of
the office give it to them just give it
to me please Taylor has six points and
Nick wins with 13.5 yeah wow faster
thank you so much
um thank you GQ I just want to say this
means a lot to me this means a lot I've
never had an award in my life and you
still don't for anything so this really
this means something I knew I had the
strength and you had the perseverance
and
um nice playing with you Taylor thanks
could we turn the cameras on for my nap
do you want to give a concession speaker
I Was Defeated
I would say he overtook me with the
Thanksgiving question gaining seven
extra points to
points for that you gave him seven
points though thank you Taylor you're
welcome appreciate another giving person